[Music]
on this tuesday night it's beginning to
look a lot like an omicron christmas
the public health restrictions being
reimposed as the variant is expected to
be dominant well before the holidays
spread so fast
that we're always one step behind where
rules are being ramped up or relaxed
plus the need for more rapid tests
ottawa's fall fiscal update a lower than
projected deficit and the tens of
billions in new spending
who is this police ask for help
identifying a suspect in the murders of
a billionaire toronto couple four years
ago and the jain of all trades like i
think something's happening the next
move for the woman who bartered her way
from a bobby pin to a house
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
as we approach the end of 2021
scientists are again racing to
understand a virus that has upended all
our lives the omicron variant is now
reported in 77 countries it is spreading
faster than any other version of the
coronavirus today the head of the who
had a stark warning about dismissing it
as mild
surely
we have learned by now that we
underestimate this virus at our peril
even if omicron
does cause less severe disease
the sheer number of cases could once
again overwhelm
unprepared health systems
politicians and public health officials
are again being challenged to keep
hospitals from being overwhelmed some
provinces are beginning to reimpose
restrictions in quebec people are urged
to work from home ontario's top doctor
says he plans to recommend new
province-wide measures later this week
he calls omicron a game changer
i certainly hope
that it is less severe but you we're
planning for the worst so equal to delta
um
hoping is not a strategy we're taking
nothing for granted with this uh rapidly
spreading virus
just 10 days until christmas even again
canadians even those who are fully
vaccinated are being cautioned to manage
their risk and get booster doses jamie
morocco has tonight's top story
it feels like we've been here before
everybody needs to decrease their
contact rates considerably and we also
need structural measures in place to
support exactly that omicron is again
forcing all canadians to rethink how we
spend our time indoors i think it's
prudent and reasonable to treat every
new case going forward
as omicron ontario is banning
unvaccinated visitors from long-term
care homes and increasing testing for
staff and caregivers but with case rates
in the province exploding some are
questioning why ontario is stopping
there this variant is so transmissible
right now and spread so fast
that we're always one step behind
consider kingston where cases almost
triple over the last week experts have
been floored by omicron's r number the
speed at which it's reproducing an r
number above one indicates covid is
still spreading canada is sitting at 1.1
overall that means a hundred infected
people will likely pass the virus onto
100 more people but in ontario omicron's
r-value is four meaning 100 people with
the mutated strain will likely infect
400 others
if it results in
a fair number of hospitalizations
it will be very difficult for the health
care system to absorb those numbers
an outcome new brunswick nova scotia and
prince edward island are trying to avoid
enforcing new gathering limits
restricting school activities and
implementing physical distancing
requirements
for local businesses it's a setback
we've lost about 400 people in
reservations but it may only be the
beginning experts say doing nothing
isn't an option and each new measure
triggered today may not have a
meaningful impact for over two weeks
this is simply life in a pandemic you
can't stop this omicron
is going to dominate and all we can hope
for i think at this point is that this
virus is
just mutated itself so much that it's
now going to have some disadvantages
there's no question the news is
exhausting unfortunately if enough
coveted fatigue canadians don't do their
part this holiday we can also be in for
a tough start to 2022. jamie morocco
global news toronto
british columbia is reporting an uptick
in omicron cases the bc government says
there were 44 confirmed cases as of
yesterday none are hospitalized only 20
of them are linked to travel which means
the variant is spreading in the
community a new modeling shows in worst
case scenarios omicron would lead to a
major spike in cases in bc in the coming
weeks the province says it is working on
the rollout of booster shots to get more
people better protected
in alberta premier jason kenney was
widely expected to announce an easing of
restrictions around holiday gatherings
today but a news conference planned for
late today was cancelled instead premier
kenny will be joining a call with the
prime minister and other premiers about
the omicron variant and how to keep
canadians safe including if they travel
abroad border restrictions are said to
be on the agenda of that meeting in
alberta doctors are urging people to be
cautious heather urex west reports
it's the week before christmas and the
mood's a bit tense are you going to
gather with lots of friends and family
no i'm not keep it small give us more
you're going to take care of the family
yeah you're a little nervous about the
omicron variant yes very very nervous on
monday alberta reported its first
suspected case of community omicron
transmission it is under investigation
dr dena hinshaw said in a tweet and we
will update albertans as we learn more
this is an important development what we
are learning in real time unfortunately
from from provinces to the east
specifically ontario and quebec and even
to some extent nova scotia
is this variant once it's in the
community spreads very quickly it's why
craig jenny says he's nervous about a
lifting of covet restrictions ahead of
holiday gatherings the delta fueled
fourth wave in august in september hit
alberta's health system hard and it
still hasn't recovered intensive care
units are still being stretched as
patients continue to fill temporary
surge beds normal capacity for the
province is 173
but as of tuesday morning there were 186
patients in icu here we're thankful that
things have slowed down
slightly but
we
we are functioning at a different level
than we did two years ago with many
scheduled surgeries still having to be
delayed doctors are also worried of
covid's spread in the community
alberta's answer making rapid covet test
kits available to the general public
when we're talking about the general
public even if you know they're not
quite as sensitive as a pcr test they're
going to do a huge job in limiting the
potential for outbreaks across the
province third dose booster is an
incredibly important tool right now too
especially for anyone planning to see
family or friends the pandemic's second
christmas is starting to feel a lot like
the first heather urex west global news
calgary
some provinces are ramping up the
distribution of rapid tests they haven't
been used widely across canada but
there's a growing push to change that
mike lookout reports
it is the must-have item this holiday
season fitting in halifax a box with a
bow was filled with rapid antigen
covered 19 tests ready to hand out to
anyone who wants a pack of five my best
friend's in ontario and she's a nurse
and she's shocked at how easy we can go
and obtain these and be able to keep our
covet numbers down hopefully keeping the
numbers down by keeping track of the
virus even if it's not as effective as
the gold standard pcr test and as nova
scotia new brunswick and saskatchewan
make them widely available
other provinces continue to consider it
there are people working to break them
up into two at a time so that they're
because we can't give if we only if we
give 25 to each person then we won't
have enough um to distribute bc is
waiting for supplies to ramp up before
making them more widely available while
quebec which according to health canada
has only used three percent of the rapid
tests it has received from the federal
government
is moving forward starting monday people
will be able to receive five tests
per person per 30 days a quebec will
hand out more when they get more from
the federal government the fall fiscal
update has earmarked 1.7 billion dollars
for additional rapid tests to be
distributed to the provinces we are
ordering 180 million more we know that
they can be useful
we know that they can make a real
difference in our fight against omicron
in the coming weeks
despite that increase in supply ontario
is still limiting rapid test
distribution to school-aged children
businesses health care workers and
people living in congregate settings and
that is frustrating frontline healthcare
professionals we're two years and four
waves deep into this pandemic and it's
quite shocking that we're still talking
about the concept of distributing free
rapid tests to people and if ever there
was a case for their effectiveness
finance minister christopher freeland is
in self-isolation after two members of
her staff used rapid antigen tests and
the results came back positive for
covid19
donna all right mike locator in ottawa
thanks and because some members of her
staff tested positive the finance
minister delivered her fiscal update in
her office today out of an abundance of
caution though she herself tested
negative christian freeland outlined a
better than expected economic rebound
that she says offers enough financial
wiggle room for 28 billion dollars in
new spending our chief political
correspondent david aiken breaks the
numbers down for us david
well donna the trudeau government plans
to keep on spending it has set aside
billions it says it needs to fight the
pandemic help british columbia rebuild
and improve health and welfare for kids
on first nations reserves a stronger
economy means many canadians are back on
the job paying taxes boosting government
revenue as a result a deficit that back
in april looked like it was going to be
about 155 billion dollars this year
could be as low as 116 billion when the
fiscal year ends on march 31st but
rather than bring down the deficit as
low as possible ottawa will still borrow
28 billion dollars for new spending and
that means the deficit this year will be
about 145 billion dollars what will
ottawa spend the money on ottawa is
putting aside an extra 13 billion
dollars this year to deal with the
pandemic for things like pediatric
vaccines and booster shots there is also
a set aside of four and a half billion
dollars specifically to deal with the
fallout from the omicron variant british
columbia will get five billion dollars
to rebuild after an unprecedented year
of natural disasters finally ottawa will
set aside four billion dollars this year
to address past harms and discrimination
related to first nation child welfare
details on how that money will be spent
is still to come these
are
prudent provisions they're things we
have to do
and this is a transparent accounting of
where canada's public finances is
finances are the opposition has a
different view what they neglected to
point out is how their mismanagement has
led our country and canadian families to
the edge of an economic cliff mr speaker
now finance minister christopher
freeland did flag three priority
problems inflation housing affordability
and climate change but she promised more
to come on those issues
in next spring's budget donna
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you a new study out of south africa
revealed how the pfizer biotech vaccine
performs against the omicron variant the
data is from south africa's largest
health insurer it's the first major
private study since omicron was detected
researchers analyzed more than 210 000
coveted cases 78 000 of them linked to
omicron they found the pfizer vaccine
provided just 33 percent protection
against getting infected with omicron
however it found it may offer 70 percent
protection against hospitalization
now to a high profile criminal
investigation in ontario toronto police
have released video of a person they say
is a suspect in the murders of barry and
honey sherman four years after the
billionaire couple was killed the short
video shows the suspect walking near the
sherman's toronto home on the night of
december 13 2017. investigators have
spent four years trying to identify the
person involving the fbi and the ontario
provincial police they say they don't
even know the person's sex or race and
they need the public's help
it is our hope that someone will come
forward with a name when they recognize
the individual's walk
the way in which they kick up their
right foot with every step
knowing that the person was or is
connected to the sherman family
or was in the area on that day at that
time
the bodies of barry and honey sherman
were found in the pool area of their
mansion an autopsy determined they died
of ligature neck compression barry
sherman was the founder and owner of
apotex the largest producer of generic
drugs in canada their family is offering
a 10 million dollar reward for
information that would help solve the
case
an unrelenting rival for your favorite
sports team coming up how pro athletes
are being forced to take on omicron
[Music]
british lawmakers have approved new
restrictions to try to limit the spread
of the omicron variant despite a revolt
against british prime minister boris
johnson from within his own party
johnson needed support from the
opposition labour party to get the
restrictions passed 99 of his own
conservative mps voted against his plans
to introduce vaccine passports for
nightclubs and other large venues
the uk reported more than 59 000 new
cases today that is the highest since
january omicron is now dominant in
london the city's public health chief
says early data shows it now accounts
for more than half of all new cases and
with omicron spreading so fast the uk
government says its travel restrictions
on 11 african countries are no longer
effective in slowing transmission it
says it's removing the countries from
its travel red list starting tomorrow
morning
pro sports are all about travel and now
new infections are quickly popping up
across three north american leagues
dozens of nfl players have tested
positive in the last two days nba games
are getting canceled because of team
outbreaks and as robin gill reports even
canadian hockey teams are not spared
[Applause]
the vancouver canucks quickly canceled
the morning skate two players have
tested positive for coven 19. more tests
are being done and it'll be a
last-minute decision if tonight's game
against columbus is canceled
we live in a different world and we we
all have to make adjustments to it
and
we'll adjust to this situation the
calgary flames have at least nine
players out of action under the nhl's
covet protocol everybody's dealing with
it throughout the league
um and you don't you know to pinpoint
where where
where it's come from or where you got it
from
we haven't done that yet all of this is
having a domino effect on the league
postponing games and icing players
boston calgary's last opponent just put
two players in quarantine
despite the masks and vaccine passports
some medical experts are saying it's
time for fans to stay home again i think
now is the time to err on the side of
extreme caution
we're looking down the barrel of
an incredible omicron wave kovat 19 is
taking down teams in the nba too ten
players and staff with the chicago bulls
are in coveted limbo they don't have
enough personnel left to play postponing
thursday's game against the raptors it's
going to be ups and downs but
you know just trying to stay positive
and continue to follow the rules it
feels like pandemic deja vu all over
again it wasn't something that was easy
to go through last year
and nobody wants to get in that same
situation situation this year
this time though hockey and basketball
have very high vaccination rates but
omicron is a new and unknown player
robin gill global news vancouver
ahead the search for lost loved ones
after kentucky's tornado disaster
[Music]
a truck carrying gasoline in haiti
crashed and exploded on monday night
killing at least 60 people and a warning
some of the images are disturbing
there are reports the truck was trying
to avoid an oncoming motorcycle when it
flipped dozens of people were injured
the haitian prime minister has declared
three days of national mourning
in kentucky more than 100 people are
still missing and feared dead after
those devastating tornadoes ripped
across the state on the weekend search
teams are still sifting through the
debris and residents are attempting to
clean up and assess the damage at least
74 people died in kentucky and the
state's governor says they span the
generations
the age range has gotten even harder
it it ranges now from two months to 98
years of the the kentuckians that we
have lost some
not even getting an opportunity to
experience
this life
more than 20 thousand people are still
without power in kentucky and some
counties are under a boil water advisory
at least 88 people were killed when
multiple tornadoes hit six states tick
tock trades next how one bobby pin led
to so much more
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
if you are skeptical about the power of
social media this next story might
convince you a woman who used the
popular app tick tock to barter her way
to a house and she started with nothing
but a bobby pin as mike durley reports
her motivation was not about seeking
fame or personal gain
we're walking up to it
this feels so surreal
it started off as a lark a pandemic time
waster
oh my
god
yet now demi skipper has her very own
house when all she started with was a
bobby pin
it's actually quite simple skipper was
inspired by a canadian man who once
traded a red paper clip all the way up
to a house so she went on tick tock and
let's get this house and started trading
and then about trade two the second
video
it started to catch steam and so i'm
like hey i think i did a thing like i
think something's happening something no
kidding she now has an influencer's
dream 5 million followers in total she
did 28 trades earrings glasses vacuum
snowboard laptop cameras shoes shoes and
more shoes all the way up to multiple
cars
tractors and then an exclusive gift card
to the chipotle restaurant chain that
gives its owner unlimited burritos for a
year
and that's when she caught the eye of
alyssa sager in vancouver as it turns
out sager loves chipotle so she took the
card in exchange for a solar powered
trailer that her flower shop no longer
needed
skipper then flipped the trailer for
that house in tennessee and that's it
right
well no because when sager gets the card
in january she won't be filling up on
burritos herself she's going to donate
the food every week to local shelters i
think the more that we can do to to
level up the happiness you know flowers
make people happy
giving makes people happy i think the
more that we can do and because we can
do it why not right skipper is a kindred
spirit she started the project to prove
it was possible and now she's going to
pay it forward so
i think i'll stay
for all of the renovations so the plan i
think i'm gonna do is that i'm
going to then trade the house for a
bobby pin again so i'm gonna donate
whoever whoever really needs this house
it is the season of giving after all so
she says why not do it all over again
mike drolite global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is downtown calgary we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]